susciter des vocations et renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers de
l'industrie surtout auprès des femmes la
Semaine de l'industrie se tenait du 27
novembre au 3 décembre à cette occasion
toute la semaine entreprises
industrielles et écoles ouvraient leurs
PES pour plonger dans le monde de
l'industrie de l'innovation et de la
technologie française et pour cette 12e
édition c'est l'entreprise Airbus qui
lance les hostilités le site accueillait
une centaine de jeunes pour la journée
aujourd'hui chez Airbus c'est justement
montré euh à la fois nos activités
industrielles assez jeunes qui vont
découvrir ça souvent pour la première
fois essayer de susciter des vocations
et puis également euh leur montrer que
l'industrie c'est pas uniquement Airbus
c'est aussi des start-ups ces jeunes
vont découvrir que Ben dans les
start-ups il y a aussi des métiers
intéressants et que c'est peut-être là
qu'ils démarreront leur carrière ou
qu'ils créeront eux-mêmes leur propres
start-up dans quelques années d'ailleurs
c'est le thème cette année c'est prépare
ton avenir pour justement préparer
l'avenir l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin eniveline a voulu mettre
l'accent sur la féminisation du secteur
souvent associé aux hommes pour
démystifier ses métiers de l'ingénieur
et sensibiliser les jeunes filles
l'association
Bouge était présente chez Airbus son
objectif montrer aux jeunes filles que
les métiers de l'ingénierie et du
technique sont accessibles même s'il y a
beaucoup d'hommes justement on aimerait
leur montrer que c'est un métier qui est
accessible et que si ça leur plaît il
faut foncer j'avais à cœur en fait
depuis que je suis étudiante comme j'ai
fait ce constat là queon était vraiment
pas nombreuse de rejoindre une
association ça me permet de d'aller des
fois dans des collèges dans des lycées
pour faire des présentations de faire un
témoignage aujourd'hui directement à
Airbus pour la Semaine de l'Industrie et
et voilà j'espère que ces actions là ont
un impact et que dans le futur on verra
un changement pour les visiteuses du
jour c'est peut-être l'occasion de
déceller des vocations c'est vrai que on
a c'est eu un peu une chance quand même
de visiter C Airbus parce que c'est
quand même une grosse industrie et ça
permet de voir aussi pas mal de métiers
différents
pour l'orientation c'est plutôt bien à
la base c'était pas trop mon idée
d'orientation mais j'ai quand même
trouvé ça intéressant de découvrir une
autre voie possible pour cette semaine
consacrée à l'industrie Renault avait
aussi organisé des visites avec des
établissements scolaire ce mardi 28
novembre c'était au tour des étudiants
de l'école d'ingénieurs e it d'être
accueilli au Technocentre au programme
visite du site et sensibilisation à
l'intelligence artificielle alors je
veux montrer aux jeunes que Renault ben
on n'est pas que des plieurs de tô on
n'est pas que des gens qui qui faisont
des révisions et on est aussi des gens
qui faisont de la haute technologie et
qui faisons de l'IA et on espère bien
attirer les jeunes les plus dynamiques
et les plus malins pour faire de
l'intelligence artificielle avec nous
outre l'intervention sur l'intelligence
artificielle les étudiants ont pu
visiter le site et découvrir de nouveaux
métiers une journée qui leur donnera
peut-être des idées de projets futur et
c'est intéressant on découvre d'autres
domaines c'est c'est pertinent c'est un
endroit très grand et que Franch
que j'aimerais peut-être un jourevenir
travailler ici depuis 2011 la Semaine de
l'Industrie a pour objectif de créer des
passerelles entre le monde économique et
la sphère académique un enjeu majeur
pour l'agglomération de CTIN en Éveline
labéisé territoire
d'industrie